back up
thank you
all right pastor chris chris wolford yes
sir you're the pastor at uh
at the house of lord jesus in square
west virginia
and uh you grew up where i grew up
until i was 11 in uh pike county
kentucky
and uh after when i was 11 my
father passed and then we moved from
there to
mcdowell county west virginia
and finished pretty much growing up
until i was old enough to leave home
there and what kind of childhood you
have
normal um just like any other kid we
your dad was a pastor as well no he
wasn't a pastor he was just
a member of the
lord jesus temple in uh yeager west
virginia
my uh uncle was the pastor
brady dawson so it's kind of in the
family
your brother was also my brother now he
was a pastor yeah
and the pentecostal religion is is
different from
from baptist or typical christian
religions in what ways
i we believe uh in worshiping the lord
we believe in shouting speaking in
tongues laying hands on a sick
uh casting out devils taking up servants
if you drink any deadly thing it's shall
not hurt you
we just believe the bible says make a
joyful noise into the lord we we play
our instruments we try to uh
what we call press and we call it press
get in
into the spirit the bible said them that
worship me
must worship me in spirit in truth
and you gotta press into the spirit in
order to
to feel the spirit of god uh the power
of god there's a power of god that can
heal the seek and there's prayer of god
and raised
dead i mean that's the kind of god we
serve we serve a
mighty god and
we believe in like i said praying for
the sick
and believing uh taking up the serpents
if god moves in that way uh i'm a little
different
than some places uh i tell all my people
that come here to make sure if they do
take up the serpents to make sure that
they feel it's god that's leading them
in doing it not
i don't want them to do it if if if it's
not of god
and i don't like i said i don't
tell them they got to matter of fact i
tell them if it ain't god
leave them alone because there's death
in this there's death
and uh you lost a couple
i lost a uh my father died in uh 83
from a snake bite yes sir and uh my
brother died
we just had a he died memorial
weekend in 2000 on on that sunday
memorial weekend to may 2012.
those are both during a service yeah
well yeah he uh
he got bit uh during the service and i
think
he lived around nine or ten hours we uh
we asked i always ask when one gets bit
if they want to go to the hospital and
if they decide to you know that's okay
i mean you don't know
we try to trust in god but you don't
know you know what you'll do when
you know it's easy to say i will but
until you try
you know but we don't never uh
make if one wants to go we will take it
we
you know it's their choice if they want
to try to suffer it out or
let whatever happen happen we'll we'll
pray with them and
try to nurse them the best that we can
and make them comfortable
you take them to a hospital if they
desire to now if they don't we just
we'll uh we just pray with them and uh
i try to make them comfortable if
they're in pain
uh we'll try to pray for them and
they're sick
we'll if they something they think they
might can drink to help
their sickness as far as settle their
stomach
they want to go we'll take them they
don't we we'll do what we can to make
them comfortable until
the poison runs its course or
until they you know pace i mean when
your father
was bitten during his service did he
choose to go to the hospital
no he refused medical treatment and what
about your brother
he refused medical treatment and you've
been bitten before too
been bitten by five times
i got i've been bit three times with a
rattler
with rattlers during services yes and
twice
with copperheads i got bit uh
lice may with the eastern and
the reason that the pentecostal snake
handling
goes on is because in the ba in the
bible you you
mark 16 and 18 jesus
uh was getting ready to descend into
heaven after being crucified
uh had the eleven apostles there the
there was judas had was dead so there's
one eleven at that time
and uh he gave him a commandment
he said go forth into the world and
preach the gospel to all that believe
them that believe and is baptized shall
be saved now believeth not
shall be damned and these signs shall
follow them to believe
may not be in order but thou shalt take
up serpents
thou shall lay hands on the sick they
shall recover
thou shalt speak with new tongues thou
shalt cast out devils
and if they drink any deadly thing
it shall not hurt them i saw a bottle of
strychnine
yes so you'll you'll
pass out dixie cups with strychnine yeah
like i said that's another thing that's
not forced some people
seem to think this is a cult nobody's
forced to do
anything uh and there's times
that well if
if we don't know a person if if we don't
feel like that they should be doing it
if we believe in living a good clean
holy life we didn't
we believe in being holy and
living a clean life and and if if we
feel like there's
someone here that's not leaving we we we
won't let them in
do things like that because i've got to
watch over one sold and if
i feel like somebody's doing something
that the bible says that they shall not
inherit the kingdom of heaven for
and they get bit or drink that poison
and die then i've got to live with that
with my
on my conscience so i try to
for the ones that handle the serpents i
tell them to please
do their best to live live what the
bible tells them to leave you're not
doing it for shock value you're doing it
because of the word that's that's it i
didn't write it
i i mean if i wrote it i'd left it out
i'm just being obedient and now
i know this is one of the questions we
always get
if if it's the word and you're supposed
to do it why do you get bit
and i the only answer i can give people
on that
well there's a few first of all the
bible said god's ways
is not our ways his thoughts is hiring
ours
uh but we're to be obedient to the word
of god even
we're supposed to love the lord enough
to lay our life down he said there's no
greater love
except a man lay down his life for a
friend he's the best friend i ever know
but he told the apostles he said you go
preach the word and told them
go preach it to all creek nations
they went and did what he told them to
do but if you
search out in history and according to
tradition
peter was crucified upside down paul was
beheaded
the bible tells us that stephen was
stoned to death preaching the word of
god
doing what he was told to do being
obedient
but yet he was killed for it why did
that happen
they was just doing what they was told
to do
and that's the way we look at it with
this we don't know
we know people think we do this and
think they don't
we can't get bit and that's not true at
all we know
there's a change every time we go in a
box we know there's a chance that we can
get bit
and we also know there's a change that
we could die
but we want to be willing to be obedient
to the word
if we feel that god is leading us to to
do that we want to be obedient
uh be obedient to that
and we want to be willing to give our
life if asked and like i said we all get
weak in faith that we don't
if one does go to the hospital we don't
put it down
but don't put it down don't look down on
nobody
but uh that's the best answer i can give
him i don't know
why he would tell us to take him up and
then turn around and
a lot of times we get bit people get bit
because
they get ahead of god they you know they
it
they just move out and get ahead of god
but they're
you know i still believe there's times
even in the will of god you can get bit
if it was prophesied that my dad would
die
he didn't tell you who would die it was
just prophesied that a son
would die and that was prophesied
i don't know how many times about
for a solid two months about every week
and somebody would
get in the spirit and prophesy that son
was gonna die
and i remember i was just a kid but i
could remember the church or talk i'm
wondering who's going to die
you know but and then
my father got bit that that sunday and
and
like i said he lived right at 10 hours
but you know i know a lot of people
think that's foolish
but my dad was a bad alcohol bad
lived a bad life
and i seen him as a young man young
child
give his heart to god and i
seen a man that was an alcoholic mean
that
beat on his kids and whooped us and
like i said now i never got a woman i
don't believe that i didn't deserve
but i just believed due to his
alcohol abuse that he went a little over
before the many a time
and uh i seen that man change
when he met when he gave his heart to
god
to totally he never drunk another drop
after that he never smoked another
cigarette
he gave nev uh cuss and i mean he was
just
i seen a man that was filled with the
love
and uh not only did it change his life
for the better on that part but
he found something that he loved so much
that he was willing to give his life for
and my brother pace eight years ago used
to say
if it ain't worth dying for it ain't
worth living for
and i guess that's about the truth of
things you know if it ain't worth
if it ain't worth dying for it ain't
worth living for and uh
i know a lot of people think we're
foolish
like i said we don't i don't force it on
nobody and
what gets me i guess about our faith is
i don't put
there's different churches all up down
this road here
baptist church of god and i don't put
none of them down
i don't i don't go uh
in their church or i don't go on their
facebook page and
begin to make comments if you don't
believe like i do if you don't
take up serpents you're gonna go to hell
or you're stupid
because but yet those people
don't care to come on
my facebook page or in person and tell
me i'm foolish i'm stupid i'm ignorant
and that's the part i guess i don't
understand uh
we both we all supposed to be serving
the lord we're all trying to get to
heaven
we're all working on the same goal here
maybe you you're not
you're maybe you're doing it a little
different i am
[Music]
but we're still post he said how how do
will they know
jesus said how will they know talk about
the world
that you are my disciples he said if you
love one another we're to love each
other
we're not we're not to speak evil one
another
put each other down uh
uh talk bad about him we're not to do
that and you know i've been hurt him
many a time
but that's all right too but i try to
never go
i try to never regardless
even when my brother died regardless how
people felt
regardless to the ones that thought he
was ignorant
he had family that was alive and hurt
but they didn't care
they went on there and put us down like
dogs anyways
and i said you know i would never do
that to nobody
and and what gets me you take somebody
that maybe get out here
and an od on drugs
you'll see people saying rest in peace
you don't see nobody going on earth
telling that family how ignorant down
people was for
but yet somebody give their life for the
what they believe and yet
we're foolish we're ignorant we're
stupid we per
that our faith has probably persecuted
the worst
of any christian faith that they are
but that's all right too i mean the
bible tells us that
we'd be hated by all nations
so for his name's sake the strict nine
poisoned anyone have people had
reactions to that oh yeah
there's been a few die not very many but
some
well i've had i've had it the
effects from it
it sets up what you call it is it called
rick and mortar bigger mortise
yeah that's what happens um
it begins to your joints and stuff it'll
locks you up and draws you up real uh
like the few times that uh i've drunk it
and
there's times that it's um
my i've got some stiff i couldn't walk
that's like
i couldn't even be in my legs and uh it
just
like i said it locks you up you're just
and i believe honestly i tell people
if if i believe if i'd have lost my
faith
if i'd thought oh you're gonna die
you're gonna die
you've had it i may very well have died
but when i've got like that
i just tell myself it's the word of god
he said if we drink any deadly thing it
shall not hurt us
we've got to believe that regardless he
said this is a
faith thing not a field thing he said we
walk by faith and not by sight
so we when them times come you just got
to believe what the word of god says
you've got to believe it with all your
heart
but as a up to this point
um i've had effects like that
i'd say about the longest it's ever
bothered me about 15 or 20 minutes i
like i said i got to where i couldn't
walk and
and i just kept pre telling
tell speaking to myself faith that it
was the word and
i believe it in about 20 minutes and i
was fine
but like now they have been summits
died from it but i tell people now that
is it does say with the street 90
or not just strict nine poison uh if you
drink anything
did you think it shall not hurt you but
now he didn't tell us
that snake wouldn't bite us and he said
take him up but
so the pentecostal religion is uh the
the man is considered the head of the
household right and the women are
tell me about the relationship between
americans well
at this church it ain't like i said
people
i'm just telling you what the bible says
and it's up to one to believe whether
the bible's
correct or whether the bible said that
for the man to be the head of his house
to love his wife as christ did the
church i don't believe you're missing
treating your wife i believe in loving
your wife
but he is the head of the house and as
far as church
it tells us he said paul told us
for he said i said a woman not to teach
or upsure authority over a man
if she need to learn anything
next to her husband at home
i don't believe in uh now when it says
uh a such a woman not to teach
and uh and not to speak that's talking
about a speaker i don't
i don't believe we don't believe in
letting a woman preach here
but i don't have a problem with a woman
singing
testifying those things she just
according to the scripture now she wants
to teach the younger women
that's fine too because the bible says
for the older
the elderly women to teach the younger
women
how to be wise that's the word that's
what the word tells us
how to be wise under their
husbands so i don't have a problem with
if if there's a
elderly woman would like to have a day
to teach the younger women
don't have but i'm just saying according
to the word
a woman cannot have authority to preach
or teach
to the men it was not so from the
beginning it ain't that i wrote it i
mean i've got a mother that's been in
this for uh
about my whole life as far as back as i
can remember
love to be able to say preach but i
can't because the word says she can't
it ain't that i choose not to i just
gotta be old
do what the word tells us i've got to
follow the word
the ver at the very best of my ability
like i said
i'm sure we all go we come up short
somewhere all of us is coming up short
but
that's for the mercy and the grace and
the blood of jesus applies then
and women are allowed or not allowed to
cut their hair
well they're allowed to do what they
want to but i don't
i mean it's damned ain't nobody but at
this
i preach that it's wrong like you see it
like you
i can't peter said we can't rule over
god's heritage all i can do is preach
what the word says and the bible says
for a woman's
her is her glory
for her if she be shorn let her also
be shaving then he goes on to say
we believe here our women wears veils
the veils because it says then it goes
on to say
if she be neither neither shorn nor
shaven
then let her also be covered
talking about a veil when she pray or
prophesies
we believe when a woman's in praying or
if she's
basically in church praying or
prophesying she's to cover her head
with a veil uh he shows humility
and it also shows that according to the
scriptures
that she's honoring her husband by
showing she's the weaker vessel
and she also always address at all times
all times yeah
if you're supposed to like said i mean
we i can't force nobody do nothing and
i'm different than a lot of people in my
faith a lot of people my faith trust
but i want first of all without love i
don't care how you live about
love without love we ain't going they we
got to have the love of god
and the bible i read jesus sit right
down amongst the centers
eating eat with them drunk with them
and i tell people here all i can do is
preach you
what the word says but i can't make
nobody live
and i'm not going to run nobody off if
they don't
because the house of gods where we need
to be
we're all sick we are that's why we come
we're sick when we're looking for help
that's why you come to church
uh and i i preach what the bible says
and i tell them that they need not do it
but if one does it i don't run them all
i i don't i'm not mean to them and
i don't treat them treat them bad i
treat them just like
everybody else i i shake their hand i'm
good to them because i want
i want to show them the love of god
regardless i want to i want them to
know that i love them as a person
and if they're doing something that the
bible's wrong hey
it takes god to help give anything up if
we could do
anything in ourself
then jesus wouldn't have had to come and
die but he seen that we couldn't live
the law
he seemed he was impossible so
god sent his only begotten son to die
so we can send us a comforter to help us
live
what the bible tells us to live but it
also says if we sin we have an advocate
with the father jesus christ the
righteous
so we travel i tell people you need to
live what the word says
you need to live it the best of your
ability but
if you sleep and make a mistake
you can repent get forgiveness for that
mistake
uh i just tell them you can't like i
said i don't believe you can go to the
bar tonight and get drunk
get up more and ask for forgiveness and
then turn around and do the same thing
over and over and over because
that's not being sorry sorry for what
you've done
sorry for what you've done is when you
repent and you don't do it no more have
you seen the
healings and oh yeah i've seen
my dad he was possessed i know
people would say i know what i know what
i know and that's all it matters to me
um that's like my taking up serpents i
don't force it on nobody and i don't
argue with nobody because i know what i
know and that's all matters to me
uh when my dad come to the altar
and he was possessed that man
he began it his eyes rode back in his
head and all you could see was the
whites of his eyes
and he began to he backed up in the
corner
and he began to beat on the door of the
church
he was in first he was in the corner and
he was he'd rubbed his legs
like he's right here and he was laughing
and he's he was speaking in a voice
he was saying i told you not to come i
told you not to come and he was rubbing
his legs like that
a life and and then he turned around and
he started beating on that door
and his hands oh man the meat
that it was just awful he just he beat a
solid oak door plumb off
plumbed down and uh the church kept
praying and just kept praying and k
and i and then i don't know how it
probably went a couple hours like it
and then all of a sudden uh
he began to throw up and
now i don't know if this is true but
in the middle of that when he threw up
it was like a phone
and in the middle of that phone they
were seven
big chunks about that big around that
was
uh like white they just big old chunks
like that and they
said that each one of them represented
the devil and if so he had seven devils
but now
like i said i don't i don't know about
all that
it's possible and i've been healed
uh several times i was in a car wreck
broke his ribs down his side
and uh that was not long after that uh
brother of mine had passed and uh my mom
knowed i'd been in the car wreck
but i didn't want a warrior and she
asked me was i all right and i said well
i've got a cut above my head
and i said my foot i said i've hurt my
foot but i never mentioned the thing
about my ribs
i just didn't wanted to worry and uh
got ready a few days later i got ready
for church
and it was about all i could do to i
mean i i hurt sabbatical i don't know if
anybody's ever had broke ribs but they
hurt
and i couldn't hardly it hurt to breathe
much less try to get dressed and i
i get dressed and my wife now she uh
she don't go to church with me
i go to church i mean i'm in a i
couldn't even hardly raise my hands up
to praise the lord and church got
started
and just in a few minutes when church
there was a woman
cain got me and laid her hand right
there
and began to speak in tongues and
immediately
my pain left and
i was fine i went home that night i
thought
i was doing all this right here i told
my wife i said god healed me
and i mean that was his i never hurt
another day
i had hepatitis c from a drug addiction
years ago before i gave my heart to god
i packed that had that i had got
i i i didn't go get treatment because at
the time
the only treatment they had they told me
that after i did treatment
about four days i'd be definitely sick
and that's well i gotta work i can't
you know i can't so i put off treat
and i got so bad so it got to where i
i i'd get up and i'd be sick and i felt
like
i i was three four hundred degrees hot
i'd crawl outside
and lay on the sidewalk to cool off and
i finally told the church and stuff i
you know i told him i said i'm gonna
go get treatment i said cause i guess i
just can't take this no more
because i was trusting in god to heal me
but i also said well you know this is
something i brought on myself so if he
don't heal me
it ain't like he's like he
he has to because i did it to myself
anyways
but go to the doctor
they start some tests and this test show
and comes back yeah you got it which i
like i said i already knew he said we're
going to do some more testings he said
there's more tests we got to do
i come to church spirit fail
same thing a woman come up begin to
speak in tongues
put her hands right about where the
liver is at on the body
i stood after she died i knew in myself
i said god's healed me i told the church
i said
i'm claiming my healing i said i believe
god's moved and i'm once
god's healed me go to that specialist he
does more tests
still says i've got it i said
i tell the church i said well the doctor
said i got it i said but i still say i'm
healed
i went back for the last test and we was
going to start treatment
i go in there and i sit down and he's
got all the test results back that last
test
he said i got good news for you
and i got bad news i said well let's
hear it he said
the bad news is you did have
hepatitis c he said but the good news
is you don't have it no more he said the
paperwork
i've got here shows me here you had it
what i've got here says
it's nowhere to be found i jumped up off
that table and i said praise the lord
and he said
well i wouldn't get religious about it i
said you don't have to brother
i will i said god's healed me and
i had a brother come here at uh
he got to church to pray for him he he
got to where he couldn't
every time he'd eat he couldn't hold it
down he'd start throwing it up and he
lost uh
seemed like he said he lost like 30
pounds in just like a month
and he said he wanted us to pray we got
we prayed for him and
spirit moved pretty good and i felt like
then that he got healed but i wanted him
to realize he had got healed
and he come back in the next sunday and
testified that god had healed him that
he hadn't throwed up another time
since you know we prayed so see that's
a lot of people think we're crazy
or look and think it's something when
they see us
handling serpents but i want to tell the
world
that ain't no miracle i had on a serpent
the miracle to me is you take a drug
addict
for me i was on drugs for years
mama couldn't love it out of me
the doc the rehab centers couldn't get
it out of me
but when i gave my heart to god he set
me free
i come up from that altar
set free from an addiction of cocaine
smoking it you name it any way it could
be done
i did it and i was hooked i
i i was hooked bad and
within three years i lost
a business my own business
went through over a hundred thousand
dollars
and god set me free i come up from that
altar to me that was
the best miracle that's far more greater
than to me
than handling a rattlesnake when i can
see
when you know you get somebody come to
this to the
outer that's bound from addiction or
bound from uh depression
bound by things and god set down free
that
is a miracle that that is far greater
miracle to me than
anybody ever taking up a rattlesnake
but we serve a god that has all power
our power
people i was telling you earlier and i
it's like i said in the beginning when
it comes to taking up serpents
in the beginning god told adam he said i
give you dominion over all things
there was no such thing as fear adam
named all the animals
even in the millennial reign the bible
says that the lion will lay with the
land the child will be able to lay
play on the den of uh what is it
basically saying the den of serpents is
what it's saying there won't be no fear
in the millennial rain
because there ain't gonna be no sin in a
mineral rain millennial rain
but when man sinned that's when fear
come in that's the bible said fear is
torment
and i tell people when we take up these
serpents i'm afraid of them
we was downstairs earlier i had to hook
i'm afraid of that's just but when the
spirit of god
moves upon a person to do that that fear
leaves you
that fear is no now you still know
that that's able to bite you and you
still know
that it can kill you that part you know
but the fear
is no longer there you don't care and
you don't fear it
and i believe now like i said i've got
no bible for this this is just what i
believe
i believe that god is when he moves upon
us to do that
he's giving us a taste of what he meant
from the beginning how it should have
been when he said i give you dominion
over all things and
adam wasn't afraid of nothing he named
all the animals he wasn't afraid of the
line he wasn't afraid of the bear
when that spirit moves on us to do that
he's letting us
have a taste of how it was meant to be
and how it's going to be one day again
during the millennial reign when we'll
live without any fear
that we'll have dominion over all things
and
i tell people i don't do it for show
i don't do it for nothing but for the
glory of god and if god ain't in it
i try to leave him alone
but uh my desire
is to win souls uh he said i may come
follow me i'll make you fishermen of men
and i i want to
i want to preach the gospel and tell
people
that god jesus christ died for their
sins
i see he's a people that's addicted to
drugs
maybe sitting on the side the street and
they're stoned you can look at them and
see that they
just blowed out of their mind i'm i'm
the type of person i don't walk away
from that person i don't step on the
other side of the street from that
person i go to that person and i
say i want you to know that there's a
god out here
there's a god and his name is jesus that
loves you
that can set you free from your
addiction to set you free
all you got to do is give them your
heart i
that's what i mean i i don't care if a
person ever handles a rattlesnake i
don't
don't i could carry on the least i
believe you've got to believe it because
it's the word of god i believe you got
to believe that it's the word
but i tell people as far as doing that
that's if you don't ever do it i
i could care less but i just want to let
people know
these people that struggling with
suicidal thoughts that
god can give him peace he can give him
peace
people struggling with addiction god can
set you free
there's nothing that he can't do just
give him just give
just give your heart to him and let him
come in and work on you and let him come
in and make you
a better person
i know what i'm talking about because i
was a bad drug addict
i mean i was one of the worst of the
worst
and if he can set me free he can set
anybody free
and that's what i want to be i want to
be i want to be a
somebody that can witness to the lost
and you know there's some people
in our faith that
don't have i
don't fellowship me simply because i
don't put on a rattlesnake show
i mean i believe it there's times i do
it
but my main goal is if i've got people
in the house of god that
don't know jesus i want to preach jesus
and him crucify that's
i don't i believe when i get to the
other side if i make it to the other
side he ain't going to say how many
serpents did you handle
he ain't going to ask me how high i
shouted but he's going to ask me how
many fish did you catch and i want to be
able to say i've caught some
excellent so all right chris thank you
very much for uh
talking with me you're welcome sir
you're welcome uh
i'm about done really you know with
reporters because
and stuff because
they just a lot of them tell you a lie
anyways a lot of them tell you whatever
you want to be told
in order to to get get you on video and
then they go
and do their thing and put us down make
us look bad and
and like i said very seldom they don't
want to
attribute nothing to the church and i'm
saying everybody's making money and
they never offered nothing to the church
and i had told church not long ago that
i was
thinking about just being quitted
because there's really nothing i can add
to it
that ain't already out there
and uh i just thought
but like i said i don't i ain't gonna
say i i
won't let cameras back in the church i
don't know but uh
i ain't let's no cameras you're the
first and
in a spell you know that i've sit down
with
so yeah you might you might got the last
interview though i appreciate it
i appreciate it thank you very much
that's a great time